Daniel asks what's the best advice you
can give salespeople in social media
dee gordon would sell my friend just
want to give you one more shout out for
that time we hung out years ago at your
family's business I enjoyed it thanks
for the question
biggest piece of advice that I'm willing
to give to salespeople in this world is
actually ironically the jab jab jab
right hook it's cliche I think you guys
know where I would go with this I mean
the truth is everybody's trying to close
too early it's just lack of patience
it's not providing value why in the
world am i doing this show is it that I
missed the limelight of a daily show by
the way this will not be a daily show
just to just to kill any lack of
confusion I'm going away in two weeks in
my family unlike Wine Library TV days
where I would tape ten episodes that
will not be happening you'll be missing
me at the end of August but I will come
back with gusto in September it's
because I want to provide value it's
because I can be regurgitating the same
old stuff that I believe in core
principles or I could go to this format
and give me value on a daily basis on
things that you're looking for and so
you know to me a couple things one
understand Facebook dark posts the
segmentation is incredible to Twitter
search you can pull people out one by
one three LinkedIn's coming soon with
their product where you'll be able to
focus based on titles so you can hit up
every single person that's a CFO of a
financial service company in their
stream that's the hit up not spamming
them in the mail on LinkedIn so be
tactical but understand the religion
right which is provide value upfront how
many of you who watch this show provide
value put out stories entertainment free
stuff reply to people and aren't just
hitting up people who have more
followers or more exposure than you to
try to get exposure to self how many of
you are trying to actually provide value
you